今回ブーメラン1万回投げるどれくらい甘くなるのかとりあえず一番会頑張って投げて
みようと思います
しています
[音楽]
あああああ2
hani
あわせるができんなこれ5000回も相当で x 教授が見つけてせっせとだけなん
ですけどもやっぱ夏だと一番会は無理でしたねー
[音楽]
ています
今月は外れ社長です梅田を投げて5000回やったんですけどもうその目的が一番会
だったんで行動では50001回目から1万回の涙と汗の感動の道になっております
滑る投げテクニックが5000回から代わったか是非見て下さいじゃあ目に1回目から
5000回目の動画下にあるんでぜひ観てください今夏なんですけど
5居るんでしょう上げていきます50001回目 moon
[音楽]
male
tee
ええええええ
[音楽]
5101透明
も全力投球ぶりに復帰
ああああああ
[音楽]
ええええええ
th
[音楽]
ええええええ
ad 種
e re
[音楽]
持っています
やっほー
ええええええ
jan
than
ええええええ
tan
wh
[音楽]
てがわかったんだけどこれが無機あるようにたら投げるか誓うこれからあっち転がって
いくとき絶対風を受け止めてないときなんだよ
これでも大丈夫
これはいあーん
おっこれ向きだマジでそうムキ大事なんだよ
6000回近くでてくれたんだ
[音楽]
ゴセイハペチ
いいちょっと開けになる独学なのは早いので入学へ投げるとすぐ辞めなきゃいけなく
なります5801
ん
ああああああ
集まりやませんねたまには一緒に少し怖いんだけど今日
tan
wh
ねます
[音楽]
オン響弱いずつ女性でも鳥の外が晴れてきてキャッツ出来ません新しい
re
ああああああ
t ジョイ
んだ
[音楽]
6戦闘終了でございます今日はもうちょっとたゲート
フォームのかけるんですね頑張ります本当に数によって左右されるものですね6001
[音楽]
無理ですねぇ
me
[音楽]
強い自分が何か楽しいここまで行くともう練習しなくてよくデー
場所移動中で仕上げている時に果ての軌道が変わったりするんでその都度一応変えます
今は急に風が逆になりました
[音楽]
[拍手]
me
危ない買いたいからね
[音楽]
えいっ
65001回ねー
[拍手]
[音楽]
pm 2
me
あった
[音楽]
[拍手]
ワッハん
ロックビーチんがぁバッハ
雨だったん
[音楽]
ああああああ
風を感じろどんな時でもちゃんと投げるのが信号
ブラのプレイ
[拍手]
[音楽]
catch a
tee
[音楽]
どうぞサンドイッチ何だっ
[拍手]
あっ取れそうな目にあっはぁっ
といった
はいはい
[拍手]
ch
ぷっ
はっはっは
ありません
作った
me
箱だめだ7000回目ですうわぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ツイート
パスタっぱ70001回目
[音楽]
[拍手]
[笑い]
ああああああああ
い
油位ふーん
働きますね
4日
ええええええ
店ぐらいがちょうどいいもなるはぁっ
me
bejean
[音楽]
ええええええ
ああああああ
なんだよああああ
wh
ああああああ
使う寝るよ
me
持った
あっはぁこれ
いやー re
me
tap me
ん食べウオッチやべぇよ今日売りだ
[音楽]
me
car
[音楽]
8000解明
ええええええ
[音楽]
たくないですよねーをキャッチしたくないよ本当は
持っています
me
dee dee
[音楽]
ん
dare
me
[音楽]
ああああああ
me
ええええええええええええ
dee dee
ええええええ
me
car
ああああああああああああ
air
[音楽]
マッハ
じゃああああ
ん air
パワー
あああああ
t ジョイ
カフェ
おめでとうございましたよん
me
どうやら作れましたぞ
なわけないん
えっ待ったこれじゃ僕ねっ
なんか昔なくサブベロ見つけてもらいました本日は有難う
me
じゃなかった
[音楽]
台パン
me
あ生後役1
ここらへんまできて気づいたんですけどね良ければ絶対帰ってきますから飼っ
が不安定だとか別にピンポーでそこに腕らを釣ってるのは多分眠り後1300円頑張り
ますなぜならピッチ
危ない
3個いけるって俺はんちゃん
マッハよりプラザんだ
wh
4するよ q 前1回目
ていた
[音楽]
ええええええ
ああああああ
ビーチいいえ
お手の
denki
me
ん
ええええええ
[音楽]
エロティック
ええええええ
抽選901
[音楽]
101951ラストセットです
この調整が大事しっかり投げていきます
[音楽]
一番トレグラストです
ああああああ
4カ月かかった
はいという疑念なんとか年内に1万回
ブーメラン投げることができましたん
[音楽]
なんかも孤児のメイン企画と言っていいんじゃないかからすごい
頑張りました夏はもう何回レッドで倒れたことか不順も東京を言ったりしている中で
時間見つけて何とか投げで無事何一番効
投げることができました投げるフォームに感謝も僕も完璧にしているくらい良いで
投げる寿司なんですけども
結局は風邪なんですね結局カブです風が良くないとうまく飛べない稲毛家としても投げ
てる最中に児童が連れて戻ってこなくなるんで異常がなければ結果フォームを大事なん
ですけども
おかず次第ということがわかりましたありがとうございますじゃあ今日はそんな中でも
めちゃくちゃいい感じ
気を選んだんで俺の一番腕生が今日はお見せしようと思いますできます
[音楽]
voodoo
あっちょ